i want to bring up this uh this this
article here from salon oh boy was this
finally enough trump and his terrorist
confederates must be prosecuted trump
treason is trending and uh our treason
is trending and it's about trump and
this is one of the articles
i don't i don't care to read the article
for the most part it just goes through
january 6 stuff it shows people who
testified it says enough is enough we've
heard this we know what trump has been
planning trump called for supporters
blah blah blah
it doesn't matter what the sentiment is
beyond
you right now have prominent media
outlets
politicians
demanding that the other side be
imprisoned prosecuted shut down they're
um
they're irredeemable i mean we've heard
deplorable and that was a while ago but
now it's it's irredeemable
insurrectionists people have been missed
crystal fascists crystal fascists
whatever exciting yeah they're saying
these people are they're saying the
other side is evil and we know it and
they have to be stopped there's no
negotiating with people who believe this
now you just have to beat them
in what elections and then and then
well you can beat them in the political
process
hopefully that's the way you do it uh
look i mean i i in the book i talk a lot
about ancient rome and there's some some
parallels there you know instead of
fighting you know up the course of honor
to become console or quest or whatever
you know it's a lot easier just to you
know
charge your opponent with treason get
them out of the way right and challenge
that off using the law enforcement
apparatus to go after people and this is
what the january system is
they
but is it will republicans ever do
anything of course they won't i i don't
know i think that look
when john cornyn
uh collaborated on the stupid gun
control thing there were fif 14 are
republicans who joined 15 republicans
right
what's happening here's the thing
on the recent bipartisan right 15 yeah
the bipartisan sell out thing yeah safer
communities and total garbage and of
course
you know there's a a killing the next
day
um
it would have been 35 10 years ago
the the the republican party because it
ha because there has to be a party on
the right and the party of the right is
going to be ascendant uh because of the
the insanity of the left
although i'm not sure there it looks
like insanity to normals to us it looks
like a plan and also their failure to
run the institutions correctly seven
dollar gas just intolerable
they're going they're moving to the
right and the republican party will
become more conservative
uh
and the democrat party is going to face
a choice between going even more
hardcore progressive or doing what they
had to do after eight years of reagan
and four years of bush two which is go
more moderate it's a 50 50 government
it's always 50 50 because there are two
parties
the republic the democrats unless they
want to be out as long as they
want don't want to be out of power
they're going to have to moderate if
they're uh happy to be a uh
a rump resistance
and let the uh you know right wing rule
then they won't have to change i think
the issue is
the younger generation is particularly
more partisan and more zealous on both
sides yeah but that's always true
so why would someone whose worldview
uh uh met walsh for instance to go back
to what he said
that we don't agree that we i despise
them they they feel the same way about
me
in what it's one thing when it's the 90s
and you can see the political overlap
according to pew and it's like
moderate overlap in their world views
today it's it's completely disparate
today it's parents who are bringing
their kids to drag shows
and parents who think that's child abuse
the kids who grew up in these houses are
never going to go and and
agree with i mean look when you get to
the point where an old man in tidy
whities is twerking to a little girl and
they're cheering for and waving to him
and the rest of the country thinks it's
like a criminal offense
the kids who are raised in these
environments are going to be even
further away from each other well and
they're not even going to know where to
find it they're not going to know where
to find values or morals or something
different than that i was at uh left
yeah they're not going to know where to
find it well the kids like where are
they going to look but it doesn't matter
right but my point is
they don't have them they don't want
them they won't want them they will grow
up around all of that stuff debauchery
and think this is fine and then people
on the right will have traditional
american values and they'll be like
these people are out of their minds i
think i think the one thing that's
missing is i don't think i think a lot
of kids will grow up and think that it's
not fine
and they're not going to know where to
look to find the thing to fill that
total
void that's you know just all depravity
they're not going to know where to look
i think conservatives have done a really
poor job in saying you know over the
past like whatever 50 years saying oh
you don't want our values okay you can
do whatever you like and not taking a
stand and not saying
you know yes we do need to have a moral
structure we do need to have this civil
religion where we do have shared values
it's at the point now where like when i
talk to people we don't even have the
same value system we don't even agree on
on how to conduct ourselves in public
well libby's right because i do think
there is the potential uh for the next
generation to embrace actual real values
but
it is
uh
you know i i look
here's my example remember 10 years ago
when we were told that latinx americans
were going to be the democrats
way to future dominance that this would
be a subservient uh poor caste that
would forever belong to the democrat
party living on scraps from the
democrats and lo and behold 50 of latinx
and i just love that word i just love
latinx or is it latin latinx honey what
do you think
uh i thought it was latinx i i i don't
know well latino latino latinx i'm
joking yeah i just like saying i just
like to see
i want i want to see a couple of
leftists fight it out with pool cues
over the pronunciation but regardless
the latinx americans did not cooperate
half of them are now republican
according to polls because they didn't
want this stuff and they didn't want to
be poor and they didn't want to be
subservient and they didn't want to be
serps
and i look i i think they're
yes
we need to reach out to people because
we've done a terrible job right now the
republican party is gliding along going
look at that desiccated old fossil
masquerading as a president oh man
that's great he's terrible we're going
to win
but what are we offering we need to
offer culture we need to we need we do
need to offer culture
i think and god yeah we don't want i
don't want cults telling you what god is
you just got to feel it because it's
there it's vibrating like it is judging
it is you you are be you're feeding it
and it's it's creating you we don't need
to be ashamed of what we believe in a
lot of times it's like well you know i'm
religious but you don't have to be hey
i'm proud to be religious look i tried
tolerance
in the sense that everything was okay
and now they're trying to groom my kid
in kindergarten
all right figuratively i don't have a
kid in kindergarten but a lot of people
do
and that's when the whole
things are grooming kids yeah they're
not trying to they are actually doing it
well some kids risk a little girl
but look here the the thing is
we need to stop
with this
fake everything is cool everything is
not cool okay it is not cool to have
drag queens in schools ever i don't care
if it validates you i don't care if it's
important to your emotional well-being
it's weird and it's creepy and you're
not grooming my kids and
conservatives basically embraced
relativism yes and that was a mistake
that was a huge mistake because what
we're offering is the opposite of
relativism we're offering a set of
values that is proven over time which
will help you determine meaning in your
life exactly and a set of policies yes
look
we know how to fix crime rudy giuliani
did in new york city he did a great job
remember new york city in the 80s it was
crime city uh we know how to fix the
economy reagan did it and trump did a
couple years both of them had it booming
we know how to do this how do you fix
the border we know how to fix a border
how do you fix the military we did it
after vietnam i know i was the
beneficiary of it i write about in the
dang book
we know how to do the policy stuff but
we need to get away from relativism i'm
not ashamed to say my values are better
than the values of a bunch of weirdo
perverts who are trying to go out and
groom on kids my values are much better
than people who want to
kill little babies my values are better
and i'm a fight for them
i'm a big fan of of utilizing science to
prove the existence of god because i
think that people of all persuasions can
agree when you look through a radio
telescope what you're looking at for the
most part unless you're blind
unfortunately but we'll fix your eyes um
and you start to see these these
frequencies moving in almost this
intelligence of nature like it's it's
it's becoming even einstein i think the
more scientific he became the more he
started to believe in god i think by the
end of his life he actually believed in
a god even though he wasn't necessarily
religious of any kind that was true with
a lot of philosophers as well who like
you know like kant you know embarked on
this whole conversation about um
essentially
saying that there wasn't really a higher
power but he himself believed and he
believed at the end of his life as well
i think there's a survey they find like
most scientists believe in god or
something like that and then you have
all the people who are like there's no
such thing as god it's a simulation and
you're like oh
then who who made the simulation
well no the the argument i love the
simulation stuff because it's like
the questions that philosophers and
theologians have been asking for
thousands of years are being asked for
the first time by simulists who don't
know they can find the answer to many of
those questions
in existing philosophy and and and
theology well of course or at least find
the conversation of course from there
and of course they think they've been
educated because they have a degree from
an ivy league university and they come
out and they are ignorant of their
culture their history their past
if you're ignorant of those things well
because they learn
you're gonna be vulnerable to any
nonsense what did prager call it cut
flower politics or something like that
is that cut flower where is like you can
snip the flower off from the stem in the
pot interesting and it looks beautiful
and eventually it dies yes cut from its
roots i think because these people have
been emotionally disenfranchised maybe
through psychoactive in the water supply
plastics god knows what but like
they need to see the math to believe in
a god like they're the people that will
put an arm in a frozen chamber to watch
it get frostbite to learn about
frostbite and those people need science
japanese scientists
that's pretty crazy there's this crazy
japanese uh science fiction book where
the guy eats himself methodically yeah
he's like a cannibal and he just eats
himself he eats himself one person at a
time but there is
it's very japanese i was going to say
it's a very interesting leap from the
start of the segment on trump being
arrested for treason to a guy eating
himself
it's not it's not as weird as the
tentacle stuff this is a spectacular
book actually like a woman a woman ends
up um criminally punished for having
done something and she gets uh she gets
planted in a park like a tree
and her family comes to visit her and
she's a tree and eventually she's just
this
a tree she's a tree okay that's weird
are you talking about like like um junji
ito stuff or something i don't remember
who wrote it for a while i was really
obsessed with the japanese fiction and i
read like all of kobo abe who i think is
just
stupid brilliant like so amazing but the
to your point about science i was
teaching um catechism at my church for a
while and there'd always be like a
couple kids who were there whose moms
are just making them go and they're like
i'm an atheist miss libby i'm an atheist
and i'd be like okay you could be an
atheist that's god doesn't exist there's
no afterlife and i'd be like okay so
you're an atheist so you're into science
and stuff yeah you know i was like okay
so if if energy can't be destroyed or
created
what happens to your energy after you
die
and that would always and i mean it's
it's very simple it's like nothing right
and they'd always be like oh i wonder
and i'd be like yeah go wonder and i'll
see you next week and we'll talk more
about you know the gospel according to
matthew so
that's so
there's like a result so what what is
going to happen to bring it back to what
we were originally talking about we're
looking for a solution to be off the off
ramp i i think it's god i think it's
people because
i feel bigger than their own body but
this is this is you're jumping so far
beyond
it's like
you may as well just say this problem
will be solved once everything's good
and the problem is solved well no no
there's a way to solve it getting people
who are in a cult to break out of that
cult is the challenge but okay the
problem is when people try and do it by
telling them christian god because
they're very resistant but that's not
that's not what we're talking about
that's not what's happening what's
happening is is is beyond
the the religious now certainly these
people are inferring religion on a lot
of these issues doesn't have to be
religious but i i don't understand what
you're talking about we're talking about
science i'm talking about what is that
about conscious unification we need to
bring people together okay
so
let's let's slow down
you have a faction that's in a cult you
look at these journalists like the nbc
news team is fantastic you run their
twitter accounts through ground.news
bias fact checker and it's like 100
left-wing they don't consume or interact
with any news that comes from the right
none
so they're in a bubble
that's why they believe kharat now
slides covenant catholic lies that's why
they believe jesse smilet
how do you get people out of a cult well
we know how you have to physically
separate them from the cult and then
help them reacclimate to normal
functioning society or entice them to
physically separate themselves
well that's literally what i just said
you just removed them you said
physically remove them yes you could do
that you could take a kid that's in a
call and get it put them in your car and
drive away bro this is nothing
you're making there's multiple ways to
get people the point is is that people
need to be separated from the cult
period i get it let's get the semantics
out of there so people have to be
separated from the cult the problem is
they have cell phones and the cell
phones keep them attached with like an
umbilical cord into the cult interest
whatever early kirk said today digital
pacifier yes whenever they're presented
with information that would shock their
system they start breaking down and they
retreat back to the cult and say give me
the things i need to believe
how do you break someone out of a cult
when they're wired into it that's the
challenge believing in god is irrelevant
they're in a cult you won't get them to
believe in god or find anything or
self-reflect or even take psychedelics
so long as they're enticing well you can
but they're wired into you can alter the
well of the cult like you can change an
entire cult's belief system well that's
what we're trying to do right i mean
that's that's sort of what we're out
here trying to do like hey look at it
this way guys look at it this other way
you're looking at it from this they
don't they
remember perspective and you know it can
be a little bit felt like i got my mom
to stop watching rachel maddow and then
i got her to stop watching cnn
and now she says things like i'm proud
of you and
it's amazing my friends brand new please
there is one thing you need to do to any
one of your family members that is in
the cult that believes cnn believes
brian stelter don't get mad at them
don't argue things with them just send
them the twitter video from libs of tick
tock of the old men in tighty wadi's
twerking for the little girl that's it
just send them that
say nothing else
and then be and then just send them
videos like that with with nothing else
don't don't say donald trump is good
don't make points don't give your
opinion just show them a video because
they'll pull it up without knowing what
it is and they'll press play and go huh
remember it's very hard to convince
people but but
people do convince themselves a lot of
people leave cults a lot of people chose
to leave scientology a lot of people uh
chose to leave was it keith reinier the
nexium is that was it next thing they
left they eventually looked at it and
occurred to them this this no there's
something wrong so a significant number
will leave on their own you're we're
talking the hardcore ones who are first
in line to get the uh you know get the
kool-aid
but a significant number will leave
and a lot of conservatives are former
left i don't know a lot of leftists who
are former con actual conservatives so
bulwark guys don't count the issue
don't message your family members saying
hey you need to watch this video for
this reason don't do any of that
because we we learned this from brandon
strzok he said someone sent him a video
now in his instance it worked but he
said someone sent a video and he's like
i don't want to watch it i'm not going
to watch it
he has a really interesting story and
then he said you know what i'll watch
this to prove them wrong and the video
woke him up
so the issue is
when you send someone a video as an
argument they'll many of people will
resist and be like no i'm not watching
your argument but if you just had a
family member a video saying nothing
they might just go what is it and press
play and then they see a fat old man in
tidy whities twerking for a little girl
and people cheering and clapping for it
and they go
what is this
it's like then you can tell them what it
is it's clear and it's like their
spirits like
oh my god what have i been doing
people didn't understand
when we are growing up we are building a
world view in our minds and by the time
we're around 24 to 28 our mind has
solidified on our world view for the
most part and this is a survival tactic
so uh in evolution that if you have made
it this long what you did works don't
deviate you have learned
when people are then presented with
worldly information that contradicts
their worldview it is a threat to them
which is why they get angry and shut
down or have panic attacks
we have heard it over and over again
from people like brandon
that when they were finally exposed to
undeniable information it was physically
painful they felt physical pain it was
like something was being purged from
them
people will resist that pain like a drug
addict which means you have to be
careful tactful and precise
when you're talking to them when you're
sharing information with them
if you approach someone as an enemy they
will shut down of course if you approach
them as a friend they will open up
so don't argue with your family members
insult them listen to what they say what
they're concerned with and then be like
wow i didn't know that check out this
video and then just send them the tour
you don't even you don't have to agree
or disagree too you can understand
something without agreeing or
disagreeing with it well remember you're
not using argument in the traditional
way look when i go to a court when i'm
doing a case i got 12 people and they've
got to sit there and the judge will yell
if they're not listening so they have to
at least receive it whether i can
convince them or not it's a different
question
that's that's the power of my evidence
power of my presentation
when you're trying you know tim's
absolutely right when you're trying to
convince somebody to get out of the
leftist cult you have to let them want
to do it
and you remember there's a lot of pride
because you know if you're if you find
yourself in a position where you're
defending tidy whitey guy twerking in
front of kids
and you understand at some level that's
bad you're ashamed because you've done
that you don't have to rub their face in
it
let them come around although they gotta
talk themselves out of it a lot of times
they don't want to right i know it feels
like it feels good to be in a situation
where everyone agrees with yeah
it is for four boomers that tidy whitey
video is like a giant red suppository
yeah right
it ought to be quite the pill
it's a painful wake-up call for a lot of
people a lot of people didn't know it
was that bad yeah and and and exactly
we've heard that where people have told
us like oh my family member says that's
not true that can't be happening we had
uh richie mcginnis's mom old school
feminist yeah and we're sitting here and
i said feminists are pro-war and she was
like no they aren't and then i said okay
let's clarify that the people who wore
the pink [ __ ] hats are substantially
more likely to be the ones waving the
flags of ukraine advocating for us
intervention in eastern europe into war
and she went what and richie her son
says
yeah yeah actually that's true
and she she's older and so i said listen
i think the issue is you're older
you're kind of tuned out to what's going
on in the world and the younger
generation is on the battlefront that
you aren't watching
so you can't believe any of these things
happen
but you need to listen and watch and
look through the window and see what's
out your front door and tidy whitey man
is that cold slap in the face for the
boomer generation look anything that
involves kids is is really going to be
you know the the nitrous oxide that yeah
you add to the supercharger and the
engine just goes you know way into the
red i mean the idea that virginia which
is a blue state
would put somebody named like glenn
younkin who is a fairly conservative guy
he's not you know 180 pounds of miracle
whip stuffed in a five thousand dollar
suit like mitt romney is
okay i mean he's he's actually a cold
whip is a great insult yeah that's
really nice he's not even mayo
mayo is a proud condiment a miracle
he's just so basic but uh no he he's
actually conservative and the people of
virginia chose him and the reason they
did it was you know kids coming home
going mom dad why are you all racist
yeah you know open to me this happened
like this happened after the george
floyd stuff right and we were doing the
virtual learning because of stupid coven
and uh i heard an announcement on the on
the classroom computer screen that there
was going to be a two day lesson on what
was it systemic racism and white
privilege and i'm looking at that i'm
looking at my kid who i believe what was
it fourth grade has it been that long
who was like uh
the only white kid in his class you know
we live in a very immigrant neighborhood
in brooklyn um which i like my
neighborhood and uh
he was like i was like okay i'm gonna
record this whole thing put on the voice
recorder for the the full two days
i i wrote about it but afterwards i
talked to my son about it and he was
like mom we're racist and i was like
we're not racist honey and he's like
well or my grandparents are racist i was
like they're they're totally not my
parents are not racist either well our
great-grandparents are we went through
the whole thing and i was like your
great-grandmom taught at like integrated
schools in brownsville brooklyn she was
really proud of the work she did you
know your grandma was a public defender
in philadelphia she was like defending
uh eddie africa and like all these guys
you know like of the series guys the
move guys yeah from after the 78 the
shooting yeah yeah yeah yeah well that
was in the 80s yeah but i was like
we're definitely we're not only not
racist our family has a history of not
really being that racist you know like
well look
we do it but yeah working to not be
raised you know i was on with prager the
other day he asked me an interesting
question you know in connection with the
book he's like a lot of people will you
know accuse you know you know you know
kurt your
you your family
served in the civil war on the union
side your your your hometown was burned
down by the confederates
uh
you know you're you're obviously
northern european people will call you
racist but you have this family history
how do you feel about that and i say
i i said well
i'm not
i'm not responsible for my family i
don't get the glory of being part of the
union because that wasn't me
and i don't have blood on my hands
because that also wasn't me
i i i what counts as the contents of my
character
and that's it and that is the answer
most normal americans will give and it's
a very attractive answer well it is
american american it is literally the
american american and normal people will
respond to that if we get out there and
say but there's so many people who are
afraid to confront these little weirdos
you know i don't want to get called a i
don't want to call a racist i don't want
to get called a transphobe i don't care
what people who hate me call me
sure at all should we have the
government pay reparations to the
descendants of people who died in the
civil war to fight for the union so if
like
your you know great great great
grandfather was a union soldier
and he like kissed his wife goodbye and
there's the baby and then he was like i
am going to fight this war to free the
slaves and end this moral
abomination should the u.s government be
like those people lost their lives and
deserve payments absolutely not uh no
corruption of blood no glory of blood
well that's yeah i agree yeah we have
collective glory in the united states
because we fought a giant war and
slavery i'm proud of my country
as my relatives my relatives aren't me i
don't get to go and like share i mean
that's ridiculous
right you don't it's like you believe in
the loyalty yeah you i don't believe in
the sins of the father you're an
individual you make your own choices
neither does the neither does the you
know the american republic that also
doesn't believe in the sins of the
father you you're not responsible for
your
debt
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there